everybody Comic Cons almost here marvel
disrupts a new preview for Black Panther
let's break it down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything and make sure you turn alerts
on because Comic Con is next week
there's going to be a crazy amount of
footage dropping so let's just art with
the big stuff first they explained a
little bit about bridging the gap then
I'll get into all the stuff that they
showed off so chadwick boseman says this
takes place shortly after Captain
America Civil War has ended so he's
still in mourning there's a guilt in
terms of taking the throne there's a
feeling that he wishes his father would
have been alive to see it if he would
have given up the throne for being too
old that's the ideal way his mindset is
one of guilt and unsureness because he
doesn't have his father there generally
there is unrest because there's no
leader on the throne we're dealing with
a similar thing right now in this
country not everybody agrees with what
he's going to do what do you do first
what do you choose to do that's going to
get everybody on your side it's a
political drama essentially but then
separately the director called it sort
of a cross between James Bond in The
Godfather which is sounds like the best
movie ever Marvel's The Godfather but
you get the idea black panther hasn't
taken the throne yet so that explains a
little bit of the drama during the
trailers that we've seen so far where
you see him facing off with kill monger
they say that this version of the
character a little bit different from
the comics represents a different side
of Wakanda so remember during civil war
before to Chaka was blown up in the
explosion he said that Wakanda is trying
to embrace a new way that's much more
open be less isolationist so during the
movie it just sounds like he'll monger
is one of the representatives of the
site of Wakanda that wants to be more
traditional the traditional versus the
new like that was part of his whole arc
during the film he was seeking vengeance
for the death of his father but at the
end Chai's not to kill Zemo because that
would have been the old way of dealing
with things so kill monger is the old
Black Panther is the new obviously you
know Black Panthers going to win by the
end of the movie it's just a question of
what trials the prince is going to face
before he is crowned king so let's just
go through this footage here there's a
couple important things that stand out
including two different versions as a
black panther costume so this version
right here that we saw at the beginning
of the trailer is the Civil War for
the costume it looks like it's more
heavily armored it got more plating the
necklace the highlights are all silver
colored you have to remember though that
it's all vibranium there's a vibranium
leave then straight-up vibranium around
him we haven't seen the inside of his
helmet yet we don't know if he has a
heads-up display most of you probably
know that his natural abilities come
from continued exposure to the
heart-shaped herb which is grown in
vibranium tainted soil so it's vibranium
mixing with natural plant life then he
consumes that that gives him his
abilities but it's something that you're
exposed to over a long period of time in
the way Kevin Feige explained it is that
it's taken thousands of years so the
vibranium meteorite that crashed into
Wakanda today refer to as the sacred
mound has been there for thousands of
years so it'll be interesting to see if
Thanos addresses that during infinity
war but even without any extra tech he's
a badass like spider-man is a badass
even without the stark tech suit Black
Panther is just a level above that
because he's had a lot more time with
his abilities he's a much better trained
fighter in the technology that they have
in Wakanda is much greater than you find
anywhere else so I'll be interested to
see if he has a heads up display inside
his cowl but he does in the comics that
doesn't mean that they'll do that in the
movie though but here's Everett Ross it
looks like he's entering Wakanda for the
first time talking to Shuri her mother
ramón de played by Angela Bassett and
obviously Nakia who's one of the dora
melash a another awesome shot of the
door mala J you see most of them are
naturally both there are a couple other
pictures of them in the casino with
really big hairdos so it seems like some
of them wear wigs at times
Danai gurira of course looking fantastic
is one of the more badass dora melash a
there is a hierarchy within their group
this seems like black panther has foiled
claws escape attempt kill monger tries
to bust that wall out so that he can
escape so this looks like it all happens
right after that zoom enhanced give him
the stare they face off a lot during
this movie this might be happening
relatively early on because there's the
warrior fall sequence where we get a
much better look at kill monger and he
looks freaky like look at his chest here
what is going on with this a lot of
people are wondering if this is like a
Victor Zsasz thing where he marks
himself every time he killed someone and
it's some freaky scars from that where
there's some cultural aspect
to it and he's been marked for something
that happened in the past that he's
still really bitter about in the comics
his father was forced to work for
ulysses klaw his attempt to take over
Wakanda was foiled so it brought great
shame to kill mongers family his father
was killed in the attempt so he vowed
revenge against Black Panthers family
but it sounds like what's going on here
is that he just representative of the
other half of Wakanda that is upset that
Black Panther hasn't officially taken
control of the kingdom and feels like
he's a weak King like you're going to be
a weak leader we need to put someone
strong on the throne that has
traditional values in kill monger is
just the candidate that they're backing
and they did explain that this really
mysterious looking green person here is
just a leader of the most powerful tribe
in Wakanda so he's the leader of the
Opposition these people that want to go
back to the old ways but the cool thing
about warrior falls is they feature
prominently in the trailer you see him a
couple different times is is where you
perform a lot of the ceremonies it's
where he's fought kill monger in the
past it's one of their most sacred
places and as you can imagine the title
warrior falls it's where you prove your
worth as a warrior and as a king so it
kind of seems like that's what's going
on here like kill monger issues a
challenge to Black Panther and he has to
answer the really cool thing about a lot
of these fights though is that you
realize what crazy technology they have
like you see it during the film even
kill monger wears a lot of technology
but the fights they have here are
old-school so they do it just like their
ancestors would no special technology
just a lot of knives and a lot of fists
these pictures really don't do the film
justice some of the costumes are crazy
this year looks like that
double-oh-seven aspect of the film they
were talking about in the casino with
ulysses klaw this might happen before
they take him into custody you see black
panther with Danai gurira and Lupita it
looks like they're wearing wigs because
they're bald naturally much better shot
of Sheree and Nakia I totally love their
costumes black panther is going to have
some of the most beautiful set design as
well as the way they use color is crazy
that is Spider Man red right there a
wonderful Midtown high has an exchange
program maybe Peter could go abroad or
maybe they could borrow Sheree for the
third spider-man film but the cool thing
about Sheree is that she's sort of like
the Peter Parker of Wakanda
the science geek that experiments with a
lot of their techno
oh gee she's also the baby of the family
they didn't say how much younger she is
she's much older than Peter Parker but
she's still very young compared to Black
Panther and if you don't read the comics
she's his stepsister so the king
obviously has multiple wives when one
passes away Black Panthers mother who
might be played by Felicia Rashad is
dead when this movie picks up takaka
remarried a long time ago - Ramon de she
gave birth to Cherie so even though she
eventually becomes black panther in the
comics she's not black panthers straight
up sister she's his stepsister but
here's the look at the better black
panther costume it looks a little more
modular more lightweight but we know it
does have crazy EMP abilities because we
see during that action set piece in the
trailer so either it's an Iron Man thing
where he has different suits that serve
different purposes like one for making
war like during Civil War and another
light weight one that's meant for more
espionage and more covert activities of
force Whitaker who you probably spotted
in the trailer even if you didn't
recognize him the first time you saw him
is something of a spiritual guide during
the film he was actually good friends
with two challahs father and now he's
sort of guiding him in his journey to
become king but if we ever get to see
the Dajjal eeeh during the film with
black panther ever has any visions of
his father or gets to speak to him
outright it's probably going to be
through his character this is a much
better shot of that costume zoom
enhanced zoom enhanced it looks much
more badass in this picture here than it
does during the trailer this person here
is just as chief of security and
actually when you look over at Sheree
again this is really cool look at her
hands here you see them a little bit
during the trailer but they're easier to
make out here when they're super
high-res they're actually made to look
like Panther mouths so she's like Edward
Scissorhands only with Panthers but they
give off pulses they probably do some
other really cool stuff too in the way
her costume stops at her neck right here
makes me wonder if it'll form the rest
of the helmet around her head Ironman
style because it's the resident tech
geek that just seems like something that
she would have created but what's going
to happen is during comic-con Marvel has
that to our panel they're going to be
promoting mostly black panther and thor
ragnarok but they're also doing a
ten-year celebration of their 10 year
anniversary at Comic Con because 2007
was when they first brought that Iron
Man
filmed the show off before they
premiered in 2008 so there's going to be
a bunch of infinity war there's going to
be all kinds of crazy stuff they'll
probably put on a show and show off a
bunch of footage
whatever drops online I will totally do
a video for but the only trailers that
I'm expecting them to actually post will
be Black Panther and Thor Ragnarok so
just leave all your requests in the
comments so the giveaway is going on all
week so I'll remind everybody what the
video schedule is going to be in the
next couple of days it's going to be
great but while you wait for everything
you can click here to rewatch the Black
Panther trailer and you can click here
for brand new flash season 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you